i want you to give me some suggestions
what you want
but one second number one number one the
number one rule is it can't be too easy
now if you think blueberries is
good then that's good okay let me let me
get this
you can be as creative as possible you
you can say [ __ ] you can smash things
together you can be like a day into life
i'm an aztec high priest that's the best
suggestion ever it was a german man who
said it had to be absent so so far over
there we have blueberries and you said
toboggan um
what is the difference between a
toboggan and a sled
probably blades
[Laughter]
okay is this a new story that i've
neglected to pay attention to or are you
just smashing words together
you said he had soft hands okay
small hands okay cool
do you not reckon he has soft hands as
well
he looks like a [ __ ] with soft
hands i think
let's tell you what about his rhetoric
and politics
actually i'm a very skilled
ventriloquist christopher
what'd you unwrap that
oh
oh real teacher's pet here
hippocampal atrophy so the hippocampus
is a part of the brain not a college for
large african land mammals
thank you dad's in the corner
and
atrophy is when something kind of
shrinks and ameliorates so hippocampal
atrophy is that related to things like
dementia or what what brain kind of
disease does that relate to epilepsy oh
good to know thank you very much cool so
hippocampal atrophy man over there
shadow orgasms is very upset
i said orgasms
she was like i'm a doctor
so
blueberries toboggans um hippocampal
atrophy and
and what was yours over there
travis manicurist and then people of uh
here what would you like wrapper toilet
public toilets great thank you
no that's a good that's a good little
suggestion what do you have a favorite
public toilet or least favorite public
toilet
[Music]
courtland park did you say
okay
it's a nasty public laboratory and as
nasty as in you can meet some pretty
freaky individuals there
give you a treat that person does yeah
okay cool well this then lovely people
it's a freestyle that's right better
from the spotless italian suggestions
suggestions to remind you public toilets
blueberries toboggans trunks manicurist
and hippocampal atrophy which is to do
with epilepsy i'm so glad you explained
that
and uh do not worry when you're as bad
as you're expecting a privately educated
middle class
british boy to be i chose to be quite
chill because it's sunday and i thought
let's not get too afraid but uh i can't
help how you react let's have fun
want some fruit one saw maybe not a big
banana want a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
killer get it that's wesley snacks and
we lag when i'm over in the circle i
hike right there to the north pole my
goal get a dog sled and i just run
through seeing people on the edge of the
snow when i'm
[Music]
take care of
[Music]
loosely
[Music]
otherwise it's running right through and
you need those public toilets they will
score your picnic if you've got a
problem in your brain better kick it go
and see that like
[Music]
put
[Music]
[Applause]
like a little sultana a tiny little
prune or a dehydrated blueberry there's
not enough room
yeah i'm a purist i use tiny eye women
for my manicurist i've been walking into
the salon i showed them my hands and
they're like there so long put out the
fingers a large phalanges and this guy's
skin looking so orangey
six foot four and he's like i'm trapped
i recognized you that's a nice little
color that you did choose on your little
fingers i don't understand do you pay
less because you've got smaller hands i
can't fail
if you've got tiny nails
when you're in bed and not a charmer you
can't get him up with melania don't need
to talk about this yeah open up the
passage between the left and the right
but no orgasms ever happening
between her
like a little legs popping up and down
melanie it's from slovenia she's like i
flown why could you please me girl
satisfied after one hour no i've still
not arrived and so what did she do yeah
she's brutes go to the kitchen and get
some fruit and she starts to eat that
and he's still licking a real fruit
eating habit no kicking anyway that was
dirty and it spoiled it to give you
images as horrible as call the public
toilets
you